يغيب لفتره ليعود مجددا ويمارس هوايته
المفضله اطلاق تصريحات يتوعد فيها الغرب
واوكرانيا انه رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي ديمتريديف الرئيس الروسي السابق
خرج بتهديدات جديده مواجهه لاوكرانيا
والغرب المسالم في عهده لبس ثوبا جديدا
منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه على اوكرانيا
حيث تحول الى صوت روسيا المتواعد المفارقه
هي ان فتره حكم الرجل التي امتدت بين سنتي
2012 اتسمت بالكثير من التوافق مع الغرب
اكبر دليل على ذلك هو توقيع روسيا
الاتفاقيه ستارت التي تحضر استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه خلال فتره ولايته وتحديدا
سنه 2010
الحرب في اوكرانيا غيرت كليا خطابا الذي
بات ينهل من معجم التهديد والوعيد في اخر
تصريحات الرجل المتواعده هاجم اوروبا
تحديدا متوقعا نهايه فتره ازدهارها لن
تكون هناك عوده الى الماضي الاوروبي
المشرق اما اوكرانيا الخصم الاول لروسيا
في الفتره الراهنه فهي مجرد دوله ارهابيه
يقول الرجل يجب اباده نظام كييف لانهم
يتصرفون كارهابيين
لم يفوت الفرصه دون التهديد مره اخرى
بامكانيه الضغط على الزر النووي
سندافع عن انفسنا بكل الطرق بما فيها
النووي
التصريحات المواجهه للغرب واوكرانيا
تصريحات هي مجرد تهديدات لحد الان على
الاقل وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات